[Musik]
ein sonniger tag im september 2009 10
manager des autokonzerns tesla gehen an
bord einer alten russischen antonov mit
dabei brandenburgs wirtschaftsminister
jörg steinbach es entscheidend war dass
wir können eigentlich die größe des
ganzen geländes nur demonstrieren wenn
wir darüber fliegen hier in brandenburg
soll europas größte elektroauto fabrik
entstehen
tesla beabsichtigt mit seinen fabriken
in usa in shanghai und bei uns
schlussendlich den weltmarkt abzudecken
5,8 milliarden euro will tesla chef elon
musk in brandenburg investieren
deutschland vox
in deutschland gibt es eine ressource
die tesla unbedingt braucht wasser und
wenn die trinkwasserversorgung geopfert
wird ruft dem gabentisch der der
wirtschaftspolitik ist das ein
deutliches signal
[Musik]
im juli 2021 sollen hier im
brandenburgischen grünheide die ersten
teslas vom band rollen
[Musik]
es ist der 26 september 2009 10
der flug der tesla manager mit dem
wirtschaftsminister ist streng geheim
bislang weiß noch niemand von dem
spektakulären ko mit dem amerikanischen
milliardenkonzern der brandenburg für
immer verändern wird
dieses flugzeug hat ist eben auf den
namen anna getauft bis zu diesem tag war
es das projekt t wenn wir irgendwie
geheimnisvoll darüber reden wollten aber
das war eigentlich immer noch viel zu
dicht an tesla dran von dem tag wurde
ist das projekt anuschka und damit
konnte dann wirklich auch niemand etwas
anfangen außerdem gehen die mit geflogen
war
firmenchef elon musk kommt noch einmal
heimlich in die region
mascis später dann auch noch mal über
das areal geflogen das ist sie sehen
wunderbare natur sie sehen grüne wälder
felder und sie sehen den berliner
fernsehturm in der ferne
und das alles zusammen ist eine mixtur
die kann in dieser art und weise nur
brandenburg bieten
die landesregierung will die fabrik nach
grünheide holen
die beschauliche gemeinde hat knapp 9000
einwohner in der gegend liegen viele
naturschutzgebiete
die region ist ein beliebtes
naherholungsgebiet
[Musik]
vorbild für grünheide ist die giga
factory in shanghai ein werbevideo von
tesla
hier werden die modelle produziert die
auch bald in brandenburg zusammen gebaut
werden sollen
modell y und irgendwann auch das modell
3 1,2 millionen fahrzeuge sind das ziel
40.000 arbeitsplätze sollen entstehen
darauf hofft der brandenburgische
ministerpräsident
potsdam wenige wochen vor dem anton
ausflug
dietmar woidke will die tesla fabrik
unbedingt nach brandenburg holen er
schreibt einen vertraulichen brief an
den autokonzern
er bietet günstige steuerliche
bedingungen und sichert eine umgehende
und schnelle bearbeitung beim
genehmigungsverfahren zu
außerdem verspricht er einen zugriff auf
den brandenburger als auch auf den
berliner und den westpolnischen
arbeitsmarkt wolke will allen zeigen
dass brandenburg mit den großen
mithalten kann
das 4 ulrich sind nach erfolg und
hungrig sind nach industrie und das ist
wo der diese geschwindigkeit von tesla
diese dieser erfolgswille bei uns trifft
oft die nach wie vor vorhandenen hunger
industrie wieder in unser land zu holen
die landesregierung setzt voll auf e
mobilität von tesla
die wirtschaftssituation in brandenburg
wurde von andern insbesondere von den
alten bundesländern in der
bundesrepublik deutschland vor dem thema
tesla oftmals mit sehr viel mitleid
diskutiert und so wurde uns begegnet
seid tesla diskutiert man mit uns eher
auf der basis eines gewissen neides
steinbach erzählt uns dass er mit elon
musk in direktem kontakt steht
und das ist der mann der grünheide größe
bringen soll
elon musk ist der zweitreichste mann der
welt mit paypal revolutionierte er das
bezahlen im netz mit seinem
raumfahrtunternehmen spacex sollen
menschen bald auf den mars reisen mit
tesla hat er die elektro revolution in
der auto-branche eingeleitet doch die
revolution in brandenburg droht zu
scheitern bevor sie begonnen hat
denn elon musk will einen grösseren
namen für seine tiger factory berlin
nicht brandenburg jörg steinbach erhält
im oktober 2009 10 einen anruf in mast
leitete eben mit den worten ein er wäre
totally excited diese fabrik in berlin
zu bauen und ich dann in meiner
charmanten art und weise gesagt hat
nicht ganz stück daneben brandenburg und
dann gehört ein bisschen mut dazu zu
sagen okay einverstanden aber eine tesla
fabrik berlin das für brandenburg 1 no
und dann war erstmal funkstille nur
wegen des namens bill maske das projekt
tatsächlich scheitern lassen
dann aber uns die kompromisse überlegt
die sich im prinzip am flughafen berlin
brandenburg orientiert haben und dann
kam der anruf am dienstag
was will uns im adlon persönlich sehen
und das war es dann
[Musik]
handschlag für den giga deal und was ist
mit dem namen wohl kaum in greven
inkassierung von teslas party im
november 2009 10 der axel springer
konzern und seine autobild verleihen das
goldene lenkrad an elon musk
ich möchte eine ankündigung machen die
hoffentlich gut aufgenommen wird
wir haben uns entschieden die giga
factory europa in der berliner region zu
bauen
das sind ja neuigkeiten und damit rücken
sie heute ist großartig das heißt sie
sind jetzt öfter in berlin
ja ja ich komme dann öfter hier ich
liebe berlin
maskiert hat an seine 40 millionen
follower
giga berlin also doch berlin und in
brandenburg nur wenige wochen später in
einer nacht im februar 2020 beginnt die
rodung des waldes auf dem schon
ausgewiesenen industriegebiet eine
endgültige baugenehmigung gibt es nicht
nur eine erste vorabgenehmigung bäume zu
fällen
max elektroauto werk entsteht in einem
trinkwasserschutzgebiet aus dem
grundwasser unterhalb der zukünftigen
giga factory wird das trinkwasser für
die bevölkerung gewonnen
das bereitet andré bähler sorgen denn er
ist dafür verantwortlich dass 170.000
menschen auch mit diesem wasser versorgt
werden
und das werk steht in einem
trinkwasserschutzgebiet dieses
schutzgebiet hat und sehr viel
sehr lange kraft gekostet festgesetzt zu
bekommen wir waren froh darüber
und jetzt württemberg auf dieses
trinkwasserschutz wie gebaut von dem wir
nicht genau wissen ob man wirklich
verantwortungsvolle dauert damit umgeht
mit dem thema innerhalb weniger wochen
sind 92 hektar wald weg
in der region haben viele menschen angst
um ihren wald und um ihr wasser ich
hatte am abend an die nachrichten
gesehen mit meiner frau ist das
vorgestellt wurden und er sagt meine
frau nennt wenn ich das in brandenburg
machen die wollen es doch bestimmt in
grünheide machen also auf dieser fläche
sagte meine frau ich sage das kann nicht
sein das ist wasserschutzgebietes ist er
nun erst festgesetzt im april 2009 sehen
mir ging es wirklich um den standort und
für mich war eigentlich glauben auto
verbringt das ist mit so vielen
schadstoffen verbunden das geht gar
nicht anders vom lack von der
batteriefertigung in diesem fall bis zum
gang hin auch der metallverarbeitung
grundsätzlich war es wirklich so dass
ich erst mal positiv gestartet und erst
mal dachte ist ja interessant
hören wir mal was passiert welche
möglichkeiten welche auswirkungen hat
das ist aber ein biotopverbund dass in
dem eine riesengroße doch gefressen
wurde
wir haben eine riesengroße
landschaftsschutzgebiet das jetzt
einfach in der mitte fehlt was und es
geht weiter es ist der anfang es breitet
sich aus wie ein krebsgeschwür
im sommer 2021 soll die fabrik schon
stehen und ab dann 500.000 autos pro
jahr produzieren
trixi hundertmark will sich das nicht
gefallen lassen
sie ist frührentnerin und gerade wegen
der natur hierher gezogen
[Musik]
ich denke
dass man hier eine ökologische
katastrophe bewusst herbeiführt
denn wir wissen dass gerade aus
brandenburg von dörr und waldbrand am
meisten betroffen ist
da ist es völlig unvorstellbar für mich
gewesen dass man in ein gebiet war schon
wenig wasser hat eigentlich zu wenig
eine industrieanlage stellen möchte sie
will alle register ziehen die ihr als
bürgerin zur verfügung stehen um die
fabrik zu verhindern
glauben sie dass sie ihren kampf noch
gewinnen können ich weiß es nicht
denn tesla macht tempo
für den bau der autos wird die fabrik
viel wasser brauchen mindestens 1,4
millionen kubikmeter pro jahr so viel
wie eine stadt mit 40.000 einwohnern
so es ist für uns so dass das
mehr als zehn prozent unserer
derzeitigen trinkwasserförderung sind
die jetzt abgerufen werden sl mit 22
danach wird wahrscheinlich dann noch
mehr sein wenn die produktion wirklich
hochgefahren wird wir gehen also derzeit
ich davon aus und das ist auch das was
wir schon vor anderthalb jahren wussten
und auch gesagt haben dass anfang 23 die
mengen die dort gebraucht werden für die
produktion das was wir zur verfügung
stellen können übersteigen werden was
heißt das dass nicht genügend was er da
ist dafür welche konsequenzen die
konsequenzen sind dass es irgendwo
einschränkungen geben muss für die
verbraucher also wir können das auch
nicht zaubern wir reden über ein
natürliches tage rot das ist kein
synthetisches produkt ich kann nicht
einfach wasser herstellen und die fabrik
soll weiter wachsen dann bräuchte tesla
noch mehr wasser bis zu 3,6 millionen
kubikmeter im jahr
das wären rund 30 prozent des jetzigen
wasser volumens in der region
auf twitter hatte elon musk
beschwichtigt
[Musik]
ich glaube wir müssen ein paar sachen
klarstellen tesla wird nicht jeden tag
so viel wasser brauchen
potsdam mai 2020 demonstration vor dem
umweltministerium für die genehmigung
der tesla fabrik ist der grüne
umweltminister axel vogel verantwortlich
er stellt sich ja diese probleme
sie alle hier fühlen sich von tesla
überwältigt vogel muss sich viel anhören
der minister versucht zu beruhigen die
botschaft der konzern sei doch
kompromissbereit
dass sie ein teil der lösung sein wollen
das überzeugt nicola risberg nicht dann
frage ich mich beim ob industrie
überhaupt der richtige weg ist
eigentlich geht es darum dass wir nach
konzepten suchen müssen den wasserbedarf
grundsätzlich zu senken und nicht doch
noch einen abnehmer zu holen und dann
gibt mir persönlich überhaupt stimmt es
einfach eine falsche wahl ist ein
standort in ein gebiet zu setzen
der satiriker zion das heißt es wird
alles verstanden und wir wissen es
regnet nicht wenn kein wasser da ist wo
soll's den lippen
tatsächlich heißt es in einem internen
sitzungsprotokoll aus dem
umweltministerium dass brandenburg bei
der ressource wasser jetzt schon an
kapazitätsgrenzen gelange und weiter
durch die ansiedlung von industrie und
gewerbe zum beispiel tesla verschärfe
sich die situation im östlichen berliner
umland zusätzlich trotzdem der
umweltminister bleibt dabei zum
gegenwärtigen zeitpunkt sei genug wasser
da
kapazitätsgrenze heißt nicht dass
aktuell schon die kapazitätsgrenzen
überschritten ist sondern auch
wasserverband strausberg erkner hat noch
luft muss müssen sie auch haben auch für
zukünftige siedlungsentwicklung und wer
das noch darüber hinausgehen sollte ja
da muss man eben gucken also dann gibt
es entweder die variante dass
entwicklung nicht stattfinden und ein
thema das natürlich vor dem hintergrund
von drei dürre jahren in folge und des
klimawandels der ja offenkundig in
brandenburg angekommen ist nicht erst
neu sondern schon seit längerem aber
sich halt jetzt besonders stark
ausgeprägt hat ein thema was uns noch
viel stärker beschäftigen mit in der
zukunft als bislang weist hasler das
auch natürlich weiß setzen darf
[Musik]
anfang september große aufregung vor der
baustelle
angeblich kommt muss persönlich
demonstranten sind da mit journalisten
warten
und da ist er elon musk
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
wartet bis wir eine rave hülle haben das
wird großartig
wir wollen wissen ob er die dürre
probleme in der gegend kennt haben sie
von den wasserproblem gehört die wir
hier in brandenburg haben haben sie
davon gehört dass es eigentlich nicht
genug was ergibt ja ich habe versucht
die herausforderung mit dem wasser zu
verstehen und es ist ehrlich gesagt
ziemlich komplex es gibt diese
braunkohlegrube die wasser gepumpt hat
wasser wurde aus dieser grube gepumpt
und die hat wasser geliefert aber jetzt
ist die gruppe stillgelegt macht ja die
grobert wasser geliefert die grobe
lieferte wasser mit ihren pumpen oder
sowas in der art aber ich denke dass wir
im grunde nicht in einer sehr trockenen
region sind in den letzten drei jahren
haben wir unter der dürre gelitten java
ich meine diese bäume hier würden ja
nicht wachsen wenn es kein wasser gäbe
ich meine wir sind hier nicht in der
wüste
und das war's mit max bemühen die
brandenburger nöte zu verstehen
danke dass sie da war schön mit euch zu
reden
die natur sei doch intakt glaubt der
tesla boss und er sehe keine
wasserprobleme für die brandenburger wir
haben kein problem wolltest bis jetzt
noch nicht da war also am ende des tages
ist dieses wasser stehen dort also im
grunde bäumen festzumachen ist
vielleicht auch ein bisschen
populistisch vorsichtig gesagt
das mag ich so sein wenn ich aus der
wüste von nevada aus dass betrachter
wird sicherlich sehr grün in grünheide
aussehen der grünen hölle heißt ja
wahrscheinlich auch nicht umsonst so
aber möglicherweise ist es eben so dass
das eben nur deshalb so ist weil wir
sehr lange jahre sehr verantwortungsvoll
mit diesem wasser umgegangen sind und
als auch weiter machen werden dass es
nämlich unsere verpflichtung max setzt
wieder einen tweet ab auf der baustelle
wird richtfest gefeiert dabei gibt es
immer noch keine endgültige
baugenehmigung giga berlin mannschaft
vielen dank für ihre hervorragende
arbeit an giga berlin
[Musik]
zugleich dringt von der baustelle selbst
kaum etwas nach draußen
tesla hält die medien lieber fern es
gibt nur wenige möglichkeiten auf der
baustelle zu drehen
[Musik]
und unsere fragen an den tesla
baustellenleiter sind nicht erlaubt
am ende des pressetermins bekommt tesla
schon ein eigenes straßenschild obwohl
es immer noch keine endgültige
baugenehmigung gibt
dabei hatte die landesregierung tesla
immer tempo beim genehmigungsverfahren
versprochen
die behörde die dieses tempo umsetzen
soll ist das lfu das landesamt für
umwelt
das stellt tesla immer wieder vorab
genehmigungen aus damit der konzern
weiter bauen kann bleibt genug zeit um
gründlich zu prüfen
interne sitzungsprotokolle aus der
behörde belegen dass sich die beamten
unter druck gesetzt fühlen kritik wird
an der verfahrens praxis rundum tesla
geübt enger termine zeitdruck für
mitarbeitende
[Musik]
und es gebe einen stressfaktor tesla für
bestimmte mitarbeitende hervorgerufen
durch äußerungen von leitenden
landesbediensteten außerhalb des
geschäftsbereichs das amt untersteht
umweltminister axel vogel die
konfrontieren ihn mit den sorgen seiner
mitarbeiterinnen und mitarbeiter wir
lassen uns doch nicht von äusserungen
ausserhalb des geschäftsbereichs ernster
unter druck setzen das wetter ich sage
wir als ministerium lassen uns von
äusserungen ausserhalb des
geschäftsbereichs nicht unter druck
setzen völlig egal ob sie innerhalb der
landesregierung fallen oder von tesla
selber oder von dritter seite durch
gucken wir das jetzt mal ankommen will
ich das nochmal an
dann rede ich mal mit meinem
ministerkollegen er ist doch eher
steigen war ist doch klar wer gemeint
ist
aber herr steinbach ist er nicht
zuständig für das genehmigungsverfahren
sondern herrn steinbach hatten interesse
als wirtschaftsminister daran dass wir
sehr schnell zum abschluss kommen das
schon richtig aber meine aufgabe ist es
dafür zu sorgen dass die mitarbeiter
dann eben auch den entsprechenden
zeitrahmen haben um ein sauberes
verfahren zum abschluss zu bringen kann
ein genehmigungsverfahren unabhängig
sein wenn druck ausgeübt wird
wir fragen nach bei einem umweltrechtler
das ganze muss ordentlich geprüft werden
und dann kommt einer macht ihn noch
druck dass die antwort jetzt da sein
muss das kann ja nicht in dem sinne
funktionieren dass das noch objektiv und
nach besten wissen und gewissen läuft
und die geschwindigkeit die hier
eingebracht wurde von tesla die gesagt
haben wir machen das hier in brandenburg
aber dann haben wir folgende timeline
hier abzuarbeiten und normalerweise
hätte dann gesagt wir müssen ja tut uns
leid das geht nicht bei uns das geht
nicht in deutschland das geht nicht in
europa
das müsste in china machen
wirtschaftsminister steinbach sagt er
habe zu keinem zeitpunkt druck auf das
landesumweltamt ausgeübt rücksprung juni
2020 der minister auf der baustelle
gemeinsam mit dem damaligen
projektleiter von tesla erwin horecki
steinbach ist stolz wie schnell es hier
vorangeht
es können zum teil unsere deutsche
wirtschaft einen tiefschlaf weil sie
sich nicht vorstellen können dass es so
schnell gehen kann und es wird
irgendwann ein ganz böses erwachen geben
wenn sie an der stelle versteht das ding
steht
doch tesla steht vor einer
herausforderung
der märkische sand boden macht dem bau
der fabrik zu schaffen für die statik
müssen fehler eingeräumt werden
laut bauplan reichen die bis ins
grundwasser dabei ist das in einem
trinkwasserschutzgebiet eigentlich
verboten
[Musik]
er passe die trinkwasserschutzzone
verordnungen die vom minister erlassen
worden ist verbietet genau diese
eingriffe in der trinkwasserschutzzone
und das ist nicht umsonst so wie sie
setzen
das grundwasser extremen gefährdungen
aus es gibt ja auch von von tesla
auftrag gegebenes gutachten dazu was
davon spricht dass die beeinträchtigung
nicht so schlimm sein wird wir hätten
erwartet dass auch eine beeinträchtigung
die nicht so schlimm ist nicht toleriert
wird wir sind in der
trinkwasserschutzzone und dort ist als
oberstes ziel deklariert worden das
trinkwasser zu schützen
doch tesla führt test rahmungen der
pfähle durch ohne erlaubnis der behörden
wir fragen den baustellenleiter nach dem
illegalen vorgehen
ja aber die füllung sie wissen schon
diese fehle die da reingehen wird er die
kamera dafür ausmachen
der baustellenleiter will nicht mit uns
darüber reden
wir fragen nach bei wirtschaftsminister
diese empfehlung die dann einfach so
stattgefunden hat ich meine das ist ja
auch keine vertrauensbildende maßnahme
der berliner sagt es war einfach doof ja
so und ich glaubte hat seine lektion
gelernt weil wir haben die inklusive mir
selbst am telefon so was von maß
genommen an der stelle wir gesagt haben
wir versuchen ja alles stimmungsmäßig
für euch und dann baut ihr hier so ein
mist und es war auch ganz klar da
passiert erstmal nichts bevor wir das
sich an der stelle geheilt haben und die
werden auch ihre strafe zahlen müssen
und ich glaube sie haben ihre lektion
gelernt fest steht tesla setzt sich
durch erhält später eine befreiung von
der trinkwasserschutz verordnung
560 fälle kann tesla in den boden rammen
alle reichen ins grundwasser
das bestätigt uns das zuständige amt
landrat rolf lindemann steht vor einer
gewaltigen herausforderung sein
landkreis muss gemeinsam mit den
kommunen schnell eine ganz neue
infrastruktur rund um die giga factory
schaffen
tausende wohnungen straßen schulen und
kindergärten alles für die tesla
mitarbeiter die tesla manager hatten ihm
viele arbeitsplätze in seinem landkreis
versprochen doch nun befürchtet
lindemann dass die neuen mitarbeiter
hauptsächlich aus berlin und polen
kommen
es bringt der region nichts nicht wenn
die leute die bei tesla arbeiten alle
aus berlin kommen oder sonst woher
kommen und wenn diese ganzen effekte die
wir da erwarten nicht eintreten denn
dann haben wir uns nur
infrastrukturprobleme eingekauft und ich
hab so ein bisschen so den eindruck ich
das tesla immer dann gut mit uns
kommuniziert wenn wir bereit stehen
sollen um für tesla etwas zu tun
bei der rekrutierung von arbeitskräften
ist man darauf angewiesen nicht dass
unsere ausländerbehörde da gewehr bei
fuß steht das haben wir auch zugesichert
das wird auch genutzt
da können kommen wir dann sehr schnell
ins gespräch nicht aber wenn es mal um
belange geht nicht wo man auch unsere
rolle verstehen muss da habe ich dann
manchmal zweifel nicht ob wir da
wirklich partner auf gleicher augenhöhe
sind
potsdamer landtag august 2020 der
landrat mit tesla manager alexander
riederer estag der ausschuss für
infrastruktur alexander riederer soll
die abgeordneten über die fabrik pläne
informieren
doch nachfragen lässt tesla nicht zu die
wir im vorfeld kommuniziert haben und
wie sie es auch nochmal konkretisiert
haben dass es heute zu dem thema rola zu
ihrem vortrag kein rückfragen gibt keine
nachfragen aber viele forderungen an die
brandenburger politik und an den
steuerzahler
wir sind der meinung dass es
unausweichlich ist den bahnhof an
schleuse weiter in den westen zu legen
wir wollen eine zusätzliche haltestelle
in süden wir brauchen eine weitere
zufahrt im norden und die brauchen wir
nicht in ein zwei drei jahren wir
brauchen leistungsstarke infrastruktur
schnell umsetzbar und vom platzbedarf
her darf es nicht zu lasten der leistung
der fabrik gehen
[Musik]
alexander riederer verlässt schnell
wieder den landtag
die abgeordneten müssen ohne ihn über
die tesla fabrik debattieren die rede
von rolf lindemann wird er sich nicht
mehr anhören
der landrat prophezeit dass die
infrastruktur für die fabrik zum sommer
wohl nicht stehen werde
tesla liefere nämlich keine
verlässlichen mitarbeiterzahlen
das ist das schon ein unterschied ob man
die jetzt in den abend hinein geht mit
der vorstellung da werden 12.000
menschen
ende nächsten jahres arbeiten und man
geht dann abends daraus nicht und sagt
na ja gibt es das alles über den haufen
geworfen worden
jetzt sind es 40.000 nicht und das kann
man ja nicht einfach mal so beliebig her
da verkaufen in einem halben jahr wird
der produktionsbeginn sein dann werden
plötzlich wird plötzlich allen anderen
schlagartig klar dass wir unter
umständen doch nicht so gut aufgestellt
sind nicht was die bewältigung gerade
dieser konfliktsituation anbelangt und
dann wird ein watschenmann gesucht und
für diesen deutschen bahn stehe ich
nicht zur verfügung
die giga factory ist auch bei
subventionen giga bis zu 400 millionen
euro soll die autofabrik vom staat
bekommen plus etwa eine milliarde für
eine batteriefabrik die auch noch gebaut
werden soll
viel geld für einen autokonzern der
schon viel hat tesla ist derzeit an der
börse mehr wert als die fünf größten
autofirmen der welt zusammen 600
milliarden dollar
und das vermögen von grossaktionär musk
wuchs innerhalb kürzester zeit opfers
160 milliarden dollar an
ende september 2020 inzwischen nimmt die
fabrik formen an
dabei fehlt die endgültige
baugenehmigung immer noch denn dafür
braucht es erst ein sogenanntes
anhörungsverfahren tesla manager
alexander riederer und seine kollegen
müssen sich in der stadthalle ertner den
sorgen von anwohnerinnen und anwohnern
stellen
auch steffen schorcht ist mit dabei wir
haben viele anwohner mit hausverboten
anlagen die ja ihr wasser aus den
oberflächen leiter grundwasser weiter
beziehen ist alles unklar ob die trocken
liegen ob die verunreinigt werden und
bis jetzt hat sich noch kein politiker
auch kein mitarbeiter von tesla mal bei
uns im ortsteil blicken lassen
die anhörung dauert mehrere tage
auch die behörden müssen sich mit den
über 400 einwendungen gegen die fabrik
von bürgern und umweltverbänden
beschäftigen
es geht vor allem ums wasser um
luftverschmutzung und den artenschutz
die stimmung in der halle ist aufgeheizt
filmen dürfen wir nicht die anwesenden
erfahren dass sich die
genehmigungsbehörde über die bedenken
des wasserverbands hinweggesetzt hat sie
fürchten um den trinkwasserschutz
im prinzip die unsere hinweise ernst
nimmt und nicht einfach weg und sagt na
ja wir wissen es aber besser wir sind
aber trotzdem der meinung dass das so an
der stelle hätte nicht passieren sollen
und dürfen weil es um die
lebensgrundlagen von uns allen hier
verbandsgebiet geht und man da
verantwortungsvoller damit umgehen muss
kurze pause
die tesla manager bleiben unter sich der
konzern hat unsere interviewanfragen
immer abgelehnt wir versuchen trotzdem
ins gespräch zu kommen
ist man einmal in die runde fragen wie
wie läuft es für den antragsteller
beantwortet naja wenn es da keinen
besonderen kommentar dazu zu geben
das ist quasi die leid durch die die
helfer und wir stellen uns den fragen
und wollen wir natürlich auch sachgemäß
abarbeiten also das sind auf guten weg
die diskussionen sind auch offen und
dementsprechend hoffen wir dass wir da
auch mal sie den atoms termin
erfolgreich abschließen können
es ist kein besonderer druck das ist
ganz schnell standardverfahren und
dementsprechend nehmen da keine
besondere herausragende rolle in diesem
verfahrens mechanismen raus
nach neun tagen ist die anhörung vorbei
und die anwohner sind mit ihrer kraft am
ende
sie haben das gefühl dass ihre kritik
einfach nicht gehört wird nicht nur von
tesla
grundsätzlich bleibt für mich ein ganz
ganz schlimmes gefühl was die
landesregierung die behörden ebene
angeht
in bezug auf dieses verfahren und umzug
auf die rechtsprechung in diesem land
abgang von tesla manager alexander
riederer
riederer sind sie froh dass der termin
vorbei ist sie waren ja viel dabei aber
ich weiß nicht wie es ihnen geht
tesla macht tempo es gibt zwar immer
noch keine endgültige baugenehmigung
aber musk sucht schon nach mitarbeitern
für seine giga factory berlin
er twittert auf deutsch bitte arbeiten
sie bei tesla giga berlin
es wird super spaß machen 1000
mitarbeiter haben für giga berlin
bislang unterschrieben
ob die arbeit spaß machen wird daran
zweifelt dgb chef rainer hoffmann denn
musk hat bereits angekündigt er will
keine gewerkschaft in seiner fabrik in
grünheide gerade wenn man hunderte
millionen subventionen bekommt ist man
verpflichtet sich an gesetz und ordnung
zu halten
das ist ein gebot der stunde auch für
herrn mas dass er nicht nur auf der
einen seite die hand auf macht
öffentliche fördergelder gerne ein
steckt aber bei den beschäftigten alles
daran setzt sie bei schlanken löwen zu
beschäftigen mit miesen
arbeitsbedingungen
das verträgt sich nicht
tatsächlich klagen amerikanische
gewerkschaften seit jahren über die
arbeitsbedingungen bei tesla
wir recherchieren in den usa und finden
tesla mitarbeiterinnen und mitarbeiter
die über ihre erfahrungen in den
dortigen fabriken offen reden wollen
die ehemalige ingenieur in christina
bällen arbeitete bis 2014 bei dem
konzern
doch dann entdeckte sie ein
sicherheitsproblem im modell es wollten
sich die fußmatten unter den pedalen auf
ich habe irgendwann gemerkt dass sie
autos mit kritischem sicherheitsproblem
rausschicken und ich fing an fragen zu
stellen
leute wir können das nicht tun
erstens ist es schlecht für die kunden
wieso aber es ist auch schlecht für die
firma ich hätte nie gedacht nie gedacht
dass ich einmal als jemand gesehen werde
der gegen die firma ist
ihre kritik sei unerwünscht gewesen sagt
wählen
dabei gelten ein rollende fußmatten auch
bei anderen herstellern als
sicherheitsproblem
sie wird rausgeschmissen sie brachten
mich in so einen komischen raum
ich war in diesem raum mit ihnen wurde
gezwungen meine kündigung zu
unterschreiben und sie sagten das sei
freiwillig ich sagte nein ich will das
nicht
ihr wollt mich dazu zwingen das war der
moment an den ich muss nicht zu oft
erinnern will
[Musik]
ich bin in ohnmacht gefallen
ich schlug mit dem kopf auf den boden
sie haben den krankenwagen gerufen
das war ein moment in meinem leben an
denen ich mich nicht mehr erinnern
möchte
und alles nur weil ich versucht habe
einige qualitäts und sicherheitsprobleme
bei tesla zu beheben
bis heute führt sie einen rechtsstreit
gegen tesla der konzern will sich uns
gegenüber dazu nicht äußern
er verlor 2017 seinen finger in einer
tesla batteriefabrik war dort über einen
subunternehmer beschäftigt eines tages
fiel ein schweres gestell auf seinen
finger ich habe dem vorarbeiter gesagt
wir müssen gehen ich glaube mein finger
ist aber ich hab den handschuh sohn
gehalten damit ich den finger nicht
verliere ich dachte die werden den
finger schon wieder annähen der finger
kann angenäht werden noch ein
vorgesetzter sagt er müsse gleich wieder
zurück zur arbeit wollten mich ins
krankenhaus bringen mich zusammenflicken
wieder zur arbeit schicken
das hat mich wütend gemacht hatte mein
finger ist ab du sollst mehren tag
freigeben
aber sie versuchen die produktionszeit
zu drücken zwölf stunden schichten
manchmal 28 tage hintereinander davon
berichten uns arbeiterinnen und arbeiter
chris war bis vor wenigen wochen noch
bei tesla beschäftigt nach acht jahren
schaffte er es nicht mehr den job zu
machen den er anfangs so geliebt hat wir
waren die fast and furious kids wissen
sie wir hatten alle die hondas und die
kameras und wir liebten es zu basteln
die online hält für uns er machte aus
diesen autos einfach elektrofahrzeuge du
benutzt einen arm um 130 kilo sind rein
zu stemmen dann drehst du ihnen geste
runter wenn du das ein- zweimal am tag
machst ist das nicht schlimm aber du
machst das 100 200 mal am tag und dann
reden wir bei mir von bender und knorpel
rissen und sowas
[Musik]
vier operationen habe er wegen der
verletzungen hinter sich er zeigt uns
die narben
[Musik]
sie mussten eine zerrissene
rotatorenmanschette abschneiden also die
bänder
sie mussten alle kaputten sehen
abschneiden und dann wieder strecken und
in meine schulter bohren und den muskel
wieder drauf setzen
an beiden handgelenken musste ich am
kapitol operiert werden
seine arme könne er nur noch zu 40
prozent belasten
[Musik]
fin de estrada ist die vize-präsidentin
der einflussreichsten autogewerkschaft
der usa
die bekämpft biomask seit jahren er will
keine gewerkschaften in seinen fabriken
haben in 2016 und 17 haben arbeiter
versucht sich zu organisieren weil sie
das gefühl hatten dass sie keine stimme
haben was ihre gesundheit und sicherheit
angeht
sie wurden sofort bedroht nur weil sie
ein mitspracherecht bei den
arbeitsbedingungen haben wollten
im ortsverein beim thema gesundheit und
sicherheit dafür wurden sie bekämpft
[Musik]
wie wichtig eine gewerkschaft ist wenn
es um die gesundheit der tesla
mitarbeiter geht zeigt sich in der
korona krise musk verharmloste die
pandemie wer twittert die korona virus
panik ist dumm
und tesla fährt heute wieder die
produktion hoch gegen die alameda county
gesetze falls jemand verhaftet wird
bitte ich darum dass nur ich es bin
[Musik]
wir haben mit den unternehmen daran
gearbeitet die produktion
aufrechtzuerhalten so dass die menschen
sicher sind doch er hat sich den
gesetzen des gouverneurs wieder selbst
er hat aufgemacht bevor er es durfte
profit vor menschen das habe ich dort
gesehen
[Musik]
dezember 2020 berlin
elon musk erhält den axel springer wird
die laudatio hält der deutsche
gesundheitsminister jens spahn
ich freue mich dass sich die ehre habe
sie in diesen besonderen zeiten zu
würdigen
sie sind ohne zweifel ein visionär auch
die pandemie ist ein thema ausgerechnet
der deutsche gesundheitsminister lächelt
die korona skepsis weg allerdings habe
ich gelesen dass ihnen maßt sich nicht
impfen lassen will
ich hatte cobit wie ich aber trotzdem
aber ich weiß auch dass ihren mask viele
maßnahmen die wir ergriffen haben um die
pandemie zu kontrollieren und unsere
bürger zu schützen kritisch sieht
minister sparen teilt uns mit dass er
nicht nur mit menschen sprechen die
seiner meinung sind streitfragen
gehörten zu seinem grundsätzlichen
demokratieverständnis und so würdigt er
elon musk für seinen unternehmerischen
mut und verleiht ihm den axel springer
erwartet
sie sind ein großes vorbild für uns
herzlichen glückwunsch zum axel springer
etwa 2020 wir wünschen ihm den
größtmöglichen erfolg und bleiben sie
gesund
bundes und landespolitiker applaudieren
elon musk
sie wollen dabei sein bei turbo tempo
tesla trotz aller risiken
sie wollen ihren masken brandenburg
grünheide und die ganze welt soll davon
erfahren wer bitteschön ist grünheide
wer es bitteschön brandenburg und wieso
ausgerechnet da über diesen kleinen coup
das wäre so ein bisschen david gegen
goliath gewonnen haben mich nach wie vor
stolz
so machen wir das doch wer wirklich
gewinnt ist noch nicht ausgemacht
auch ohne endgültige baugenehmigung
tesla macht immer weiter tempo und
schafft fakten
[Musik]